between 2010 and 2015 the average income
between uh the average income difference
between the top 20% and the bottom 20%
of Americans known as the rich-poor gap
grew from about $29,000 to over a
hundred and eighty nine thousand dollars
according to Census Bureau data and
during that time this divide widened in
all 100 of the country's largest metro
areas as sort of pointed out by this
chart and much of what you see here is
because computers and robots are
performing more and more new tasks this
is something that we talked about
frequently uh for we've been talking
about it for years really but the 2016
presidential candidates did not want to
talk about it Donald Trump still doesn't
want to talk about it because if it's
sort of fake populist persona that can't
and won't be backed up by actual
policies to help the actual worker as we
extensively talked about on yesterday's
program this makes the work of
specialized laborers more efficient
which makes the rich richer and
stakeholders benefit from the efficiency
by making the rich richer and Magadh up
when machines replace low-skilled
workers that makes the poor poorer so
this trend is expected to continue there
are a number of different factors right
now that are increasing the wealth gap
the income and wealth gaps and Donald
Trump's tax proposal would make that
even worse we've we've talked about a
lot of those issues but robots and
automation are also going to be a factor
it's expected to continue according to a
recent study by PricewaterhouseCoopers
around 38 percent of American jobs could
be at high risk of being replaced by
automation by the early 2030s and
depending on which study we looked at I
mean I've told you about studies that
say as high as as many as half of all
jobs are at risk of being automated away
over the next 20 or 25 years the most
vulnerable industries are ones with low
skill workers like retail transportation
storage manufacturing and this is
putting a huge strain
on Americans in the lowest income
brackets income growth in the u.s. is
falling behind the costs of housing that
go up and the costs of basic needs that
are going up the Labor Department for
example says that the average
residential rental costs have gone up
three point nine percent in just a year
which is really a lot when you think
about that on a year-over-year basis and
not surprisingly four of the five cities
with the biggest rich-poor gap increase
were cities with thriving high-tech
industries and if we take a look at that
same graph from earlier San Francisco
San Jose in Silicon Valley
Austin Texas Seattle Washington and many
of the cities that are high on the list
like Bridgeport Connecticut for example
have low-income workers that mostly work
in the industry as I mentioned that are
most vulnerable to automation retail
manufacturing etc the gap between the
super-rich meaning the top 5% and the
middle class the middle 20% also grew
considerably by nearly fifty nine
thousand dollars as this next graph sort
of points out and even the gap and this
is this is one that may be surprising to
you to some degree even the gap within
the middle class has grown the divide
between households at the 30th and 80th
percentile increased by an average of
$9,000 Cole is one of these industries
that is being affected which is why the
war on coal that Donald Trump talks
about is non-existent and why trying to
prop up the coal industry is actually it
not only is it pointless and aimless and
bad for the environment it's also
anti-capitalistic because the coal
industry in the free market is
increasingly a dying industry Automation
is making college degrees more valuable
educated people are needed to design and
maintain the computer systems and the
robots while there are fewer low-skilled
jobs out there because of those
computers and robots being developed by
the skilled workers so there are
arguments to be made that automation is
a good thing it'll free P
to do work that is more creative or
analytical but it's not as though all
people that are in the truck driving
industry or fry cooks will all of a
sudden once their jobs are automated
away become opera singers or
philosophers or computer programmers so
I've said this before I'll say it again
Automation is happening if we are to
successfully uh synthesize the effects
of automation we're going to need a
paradigm shift in terms of how we think
of the relationship to work and it's
clear that the Trump administration I
mean it's laughable to even consider
whether the Trump administration might
be equipped to deal with that but more
broadly the political apparatus of the
United States is not really equipped to
deal with that basic income is something
that we're talking about more and more
we know if you look historically the the
progress of technology has not in any
significant way been stopped because of
the jobs that it was going to kill and
the idea of replacing cars of replacing
the horse buggy drivers with cars wasn't
going to be stopped because the buggy
drivers were going to lose their jobs
imagine if everything we've seen happen
in the automotive industry never
happened because we were just too
worried that the horse buggy drivers
were going to lose their jobs so I don't
believe that resisting this is a logical
path forward I think that working with
it makes a lot more sense and it's going
to be theirs at some point there's going
to be a split and some would argue the
split is already happening because of
the drastic increase in wealth
inequality that we're seeing either we
are going to be prepared to take on this
changing dynamic in a way that will
improve society for everyone or for most
people or wealth inequality will
continue to explode and the problems
that we currently have as a result of
that wealth inequality are going to get
worse and worse and worse and that's why
we really need to be thinking about
universal basic income we need to be
continuing to think about and it's
laughable given the conversation about
health care that we have but we
looking at disconnecting health
insurance from employment especially
when machines replace your job it it
more acutely makes no sense to connect
health insurance to employment so I
don't think we're even close to ready to
deal with these issues I think a lot of
people are still in denial some of those
people email me on a regular basis but
it's happening it's coming and it's
either going to get much much worse or
if we get together as a society and
think about how to improve circumstances
things could get better the reason I'm
skeptical is that I mean look at climate
change with many issues human society at
large right now is not really willing to
be forward-looking to the degree that is
necessary to deal with a lot of these
issues tell me what you think about this
I'm on Twitter at the Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show
we'll take a break and be back with more
from Las Vegas Nevada right after this